welcome to another episode of the
wednesday checkup today's topic
covet 19 because there's more confusion
than ever before and i think there are
two main driving factors behind this the
media
and two our leadership more specifically
president trump i'll be addressing both
of those points
using several examples in this video
let's get started
you don't have a medical background
you're not a scientist
yet you're claiming this substance which
has not been studied in any meaningful
way can cure covid
and you have a financial stake in the
company you would profit from it if this
is being sold widely morally is that
right
well you know i was contacted on easter
sunday after
you know that i've told the whole
country to pray up for the answer for
this pandemic so this guy called me on
easter sunday and said he had an answer
to the virus
this is all baloney while i'm very
angry for him coming out and spewing
this misinformation about oleander or
oleandrin
oil which is poisonous there's actually
cardiac toxicity that comes from this
what i'm more upset about is cnn
giving this person a platform what was
the purpose of
bringing him on and making this into a
national story when it wasn't
this actually led to president trump
being asked this question by a reporter
andrew
has have you heard of that as a possible
therapy for i've heard of it yes go
ahead press the fba
no i haven't i have it is it something
you would support is it something that
people are talking about very strongly
we'll look at it he clearly has no idea
what the reporter is asking
and the only reason the report is asking
this question is because it was seen on
cnn i'm also
really upset with cnn that they're
wasting air time on mike lindell
where we have great scientists that have
hard-hitting stories that are really
important to tell
including that the black population in
the united states
is being disproportionately affected by
covid19 that
there's certain difficulties in
obtaining tests in low socioeconomic
neighborhoods in the us
why are we talking to the my pillow guy
let's move on
to a tweet that president trump himself
retweeted
stating that only 9 000 people
incorrectly stated
that only 9 000 people have died of
covet 19
thus far the tweet actually ended up
being removed for violating terms of
service but let's talk about where they
got this number from this six percent
figure or 9 000 deaths
actually came from a legitimate cdc
document that said
94 of the deaths related to covet 19
had several causes of death listed on
the death certificate and that's
actually not that surprising it is very
rare for an individual to have a single
thing listed on their death certificate
because for those of us who actually
fill out death certificates
we know we put a primary cause of death
as well as
contributing causes of death for example
if you have
hypertension or your bmi falls in the
obese category
you technically have risk factors and
diagnoses that contributed to your
demise to your loss of life but covet 19
is what caused it these are just
extra things that made you high risk and
more susceptible to coven 19. that
doesn't mean
it wasn't coveted 19 that led to your
death
it's very rare that a person dies
specifically of a single
illness so it is completely inaccurate
to say that
only six percent of people died as a
result of covet 19. 100
of those people died with covet 19 and
from covet 19 and some of them
had extra things listed on their death
certificate such as respiratory failure
where they get respiratory failure from
covid
19. it's misinformation at its finest
and it causes you to think
oh covet 19 is not as deadly as it looks
covid19
takes our most fragile patients and it
leads to a high death rate
it also affects the younger generations
and creates complications for them at a
lower death rate
but still a serious illness that we must
not write off
let's look at this headline from
kpbs.org
covid19 and the brain quotes
you should be afraid not only do i think
this is an absolutely trash headline
it capitalizes on humans being afraid of
covid19
in hopes that they would click on this
article and read it and they would raise
more money
via advertising i think this is the
worst type of healthcare reporting
because it's dishonest
while we are seeing some long-term
effects related to covid19 we also see
long-term effects of any person that's
admitted into an icu if you're in an icu
for a heart attack for diabetic
ketoacidosis
for sepsis coming out of that icu will
be a long recovery process your lungs
will be scarred you will have
inflammation in your body
at certain times you'll have
neurological symptoms brain fog
this is classic icu protocol in coming
out of the icu it is not the norm to see
long-term
health effects of covid19 most people
will get better with covid19
most people will recover and not have
any serious long-lasting symptoms there
will be a subset of the population
that will have some lingering symptoms
just like they do
with a serious case of influenza just
like they do with a heart attack
or with any of other reasonable number
of illnesses
the truth is we don't know what the
long-term effects are of covid19
we're studying them and if you ask
doctors they'll tell you the truth
they'll tell you that in some cases
they're seeing effects on the brain on
the heart
and covet 19 is unique because it seems
to affect different organs throughout
your body not just your lungs but again
this
isn't the case for the majority of cases
we should not report
on medical stories this way hey it
causes healthcare-related anxiety which
i see
day in and day out especially now and
two it's not going to change anyone's
minds that disagrees with you the people
who think kovit19 is a hoax will not be
convinced by your over dramatic news
reporting there's no reason to do it
next let's look at this tweet by
president trump on august 22nd the deep
state or whoever over at the fda is
making it very difficult for drug
companies to get people
in order to test the vaccine and
therapeutics obviously they are hoping
to delay the answer until after november
3rd
must focus on speed and saving lives if
you are a president of a nation
and you have at your disposal the fda
the cdc the last thing you should be
doing
is trying to make them look bad the more
you put out into the public that the fda
has deep state actors or the cdc's not
being honest
whatever it is you're tweeting you're
losing the faith of the american people
in these institutions
the scientists and doctors that are
working day in and day out at the cdc
and fda they're not
hiding treatments and letting people die
because
they care about who wins the
presidential uh election what they do
care about
is making sure everything's done with
integrity with scientific rigor
with accuracy and that's how it must
continue because guess what president
trump when we do have
a good vaccine that's safe that works
you're going to need the public's trust
in order for them to get this vaccine
and with tweets like that
you're making it very very difficult
final point i want to talk about is
schools reopening the fact that there's
some infections happening at these
schools universities local institutions
and i feel like we're approaching these
stories with a lot of irrationality a
lot of panic
remember my mantra from the beginning of
covet 19 has been stay alert not anxious
the reason i say this is because there's
constantly headlines university of
alabama has over 1 000 cases in a month
school district in georgia has 20 cases
of covert 19.
we're going to see cases in schools in
our cities
in our states as we begin the reopening
process the danger with covid19
is that it can spread like wildfire as
long as we keep these numbers low
that's what's important we need to
protect the population who is most
vulnerable
we need to make smart decisions with
good quality data not politicize the
topic
not try and scare people and reality is
as we reopen schools
as we reopen shopping areas gyms we will
see a small spike in covet 19 cases
it's not about seeing a small uptick and
panicking that's the last thing we want
students let's be mature let's not throw
parties tonight several yukon
students have been evicted from
on-campus housing after this
packed party let's not say forget
covid19
look odds are if you're young and you
get covered 19
it's not going to be the end of the
world but you can potentially spread it
to many other people and when you go to
a party a room full of 100 people
it takes one to get many other sick who
then will travel home and get many
others sick it's about the speed at
which it spreads
focus on school for a short period of
time wear a mask
and at the end of the day just be
reasonable something really important to
talk about when it comes to covering
covet 19
is that people really look down upon
those
who are misinformed and just like i do
with vaccine hesitant parents
i do not rush to judge them that is a
surefire way
to get them to never see your point of
view to never understand truly how
science works
think about how you can connect with
them to educate them on
why it's not stupid and why they should
take care because right now as a person
without a scientific background it is
confusing you do hear contradicting
opinions on the news
in our politics so media president trump
and everyone in between let's take a
more empathetic approach here
and be smart with the things we're
putting out to the general public we all
want the same thing
less deaths a healthier and happier
public and the end of covid19 and the
only way we can get there
is by working together if you want to
check out some of my other interesting
content
about covet19 click here or for more
lighthearted playlists that i put
together special for you
click here as always stay happy and
healthy